no one here said you should be dumb I'm
not saying that anybody said that you
just made fun of women for being dumb
and not only that that's not funny
I love it on people
look at
it look at I'm smart I get good at
everything I do I was probably top one
two percent in volleyball in the entire
of all the people that start I was
really really good I'm I'm the top I
don't know 1 000 podcasts in the United
States killing it on the podcast I have
one of the biggest podcasts in the world
I get good at everything I do I I'm I
sing I do music when I'm a smart and I'm
not even trying to toot my own horn but
it's like I am smart you're killing it
guys don't really care that much it's a
bonus sure some guys find it nice but
it's not a selling point
well not for you and not for some other
people but